I feel like having four is so much more
Zen I feel really calm and Zen I feel
like they all love each other the baby
really like brought back like you know
my two older kids would fight a little
bit and now since the baby's here
everyone gets along everyone loves each
other I'm rolling with it it's just it
is really Zen it feels really equal and
calm and great Kim Kardashian dishin on
her four kids but is she planning to
make it six like mom Kris I think this
is it just because I am so busy doing so
many other things I want to make sure
each kid gets so much of my attention I
could I would do even numbers so I could
go to more but I won't
I won't I think that's just like I think
I'll go crazy but I think 4 is the
perfect magic number for me it's so
important to give the perfect amount of
attention to every kid and so especially
with school now and everything that I'm
doing I really just can't extend myself
beyond this everyone always asks like
what's next and I'm like I'm just gonna
focus and do what I'm doing I can't do
anything else
et was with came to talk her new
shapewear line skin and I feel like I've
been making and wearing shapewear for 15
years just because I've been cutting it
up and always making it my own whether
it's trying to find different you know
darker tones because the shapewear I
mean at least back then it was you know
I would only find one shade of nude and
it was never my color so I would always
take teabags
and dye them in the sink with the tea
bags and try to get like the perfect
color and so I really for the longest
time have been cutting it up if I've had
a skirt with a slit so now that I have
like a one legged solution short I feel
like I have all the solutions for the
problems that I've been trying to fix
for so long so in the shapewear space I
had only seen extra small to three XL so
we have double extra small to 4 XL and
then some styles 5 XL so you know and I
think it's really all about enhancing
what you have and so I think like some
people are like well why does
double X small need shapewear but it's
really solution we're and we're really
you know we have this most amazing bra
an amazing brief we have the one it's
just it's just really smooth and there's
something for everyone we have three
different tensions so you can go just
you know from a light smooth to more
intense and I'm just I'm so happy that I
took my time developing something that I
really really love and if anybody knows
this space I do and I just I feel so
good about bringing something to the
marketplace that I really haven't seen
before
and Toby Kanye has been nothing but
supportive of Kim's growing Empire he's
just super supportive he actually we
were just like in a design meeting he
was drawing out the loge like the name
and we loved it so much that we made
that our logo just his drawing we're
super involved in each other's you know
brands and what's going on and he you
know was just writing out the name and
it just it worked so well
hey I'm also gay BG a preview of the
pieces every time I have found shapewear
it has always been maybe one or two
shades the shade would be too light for
me and letting the other shade would be
too dark for me and maybe a black so we
have nine different options one of my
favorites I mean the classic short is
just what I always wear and will always
be my staple it does have these like
butt pockets that are just too sheer a
more sheer fabric on the butt so that it
does kind of just like lift and sculpt a
little bit I love that we have this like
silicone band on the inside so it really
prevents from rolling color so this
solution short the one legged solution
short is everything I mean anytime you
wear a slit to try to get the factories
to understand what I was saying when I
wanted a one legged solution short that
was really a challenging but amazing
project because every time I'd wear
something with a slit I still wanted
that support everywhere else
so I was at a shoot one time with Kylie
and she was cutting up her shapewear
just like I had and I was like okay wait
a minute I'm in the in the middle of
making this I would send her samples and
we would go back and forth to make sure
that this is what she loved and what I
loved and I thought if her and I are
both doing the same thing then there's
other people out there that need that
one of my favorite things is the
bodysuit there is go with this one the
bra top of it just like completely
shapes your boobs so good and smooth
that we ended up making it into a bra
like engineering it and just like having
our standalone profits in here somewhere
but I wear this as like a camisole under
something so if I have pants I'll just
like are a suit like one of these I'll
just put it on and wear this as a
camisole underneath whatever I have
jeans suit and it does come without the
legs as well so this was like my new
go-to camisole
I'm obsessed it's so comfortable I think
what's really different is once you feel
how soft the fabric is you just honestly
it doesn't feel really restricting so
many people that I had fit this and try
this had not been shapewear wears
because they always felt really
claustrophobic and too constricted so
when they tried this and they felt how
comfortable the fabric is they loved it
and that just made me so happy that I
felt like you know we have a whole new
audience of people that finally feel
really confident wearing the pieces and
in a candid moment Kim revealed even she
gets insecure sometimes all the time but
I am the kind of person that if I have
like cellulite and I see if I picture
myself I'll go to the gym I'll figure it
out I use it as motivation but I use our
solution where for so many things for
you know lining under clothes for just
if something is itchy instead of like
lining a pair of pain
it's just it's this comfort that makes
me feel really secure and safe but of
course I have insecurities all the time
and just got to roll with it and find
little tricks and tips that make you
feel a confident and that's what this is
for me
[Music]